and a survey that the Clark County
School Board of Trustees commission
revealed an overwhelming number of staff
and students have a negative view of the
board nearly 12 000 people responded to
The Climate survey 76 percent of
respondents say the board is not having
a positive impact on schools and student
outcomes another 80 percent say the
board is not making effective decisions
according to the survey of the seven
regular board meetings in the fall of
2021 none discussed student outcomes it
is my hope and my aspiration I'm an end
of the superintendent is also supportive
of this that we continue
conducting some level of
assessment on an annual basis like this
so that we can see our progress
respondents have a more favorable view
of the current Board of Trustees two new
members were sworn in January and a new
board president was also picked